hi I'm Charles graver with Wired
magazine we're in the wired offices here
in the contine ass building in new york
12th of February 2009 I've got a box of
medico cylinders that we're going to be
testing we've got to buy us booze Manus
and Mark Tobias here who are going to be
opening these cylinders we're going to
take them one by one without showing
them put them into the vise they're
going to use their tools and technology
to try and crack them open and less than
10 minutes each so let's get started go
I'm using code signing keys with six
pins there's no helping the device is
slipping a little bit oh yeah let's see
one or two more pins was one open
this is a five-pin I'm gonna call em
three open
open
for
okay so that's six locks we went through
the fastest time was a minute 55 that
was like five the slowest time for
picking was eight minutes 13 seconds all
of them were below the ten-minute
threshold that's the absolute minimum or
the more stringent threshold for for
high security locks
that's the UL standard the B MHA this is
the most there's more stringent that's
up to 15 minute cracks right and so
essentially all these locks failed
according to the standards set by the
industry all these locks fail to be high
security click OK it's open